[Musik]
in dieser geschichte geht es um den
bestatter fazli um die frage wie wir
unser leben und wie wir unseren tod
verbringen
was wissen sie über die
welt verstreut
risky
aussergewöhnlichen todesfall
und faktische der gerichtsmedizin was
sie da klar gemacht
heinz langhorst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unser fazit war 20 jahre alt als seine
großmutter starb die familie vergeblich
nach einem muslimischen bestatter suchte
vermutlich hätten andere das gleiche
problem dachte er sich und fragte seinen
vater ob sie sich selbstständig machen
wollten nach zehn anfangsjahren wickeln
kathrin junior senior mittlerweile rund
10 islamische beerdigungen pro monat ab
mehrheitlich für albanische landsleute
die rituellen waschungen finden auf dem
areal des friedhofes zürich witikon
stadt nahe dem flughafen denn die
meisten leichname werden nach hause
geflogen
die männlichen toten wester zusammen mit
seinem vater frauen dürften dagegen nur
von frauen gewaschen werden in solchen
fällen kommt jeweils die mutter mit
was dann sitzt du bist wie
das ist eigentlich so
unterschiedliche durch shampoo
schwarzen damit nicht nass wartet und
natürlich komisch
[Musik]
zwei onkel und ein user des verstorbenen
sind gekommen die eltern und die
geschwister sind bereits nach kosovo
ausgeflogen die zeit drängt vom tod bis
zur beisetzung dürfen nicht mehr als 48
stunden vergehen
[Musik]
das ist
ja der moslems im indischen stil ikone
rasche das ist so festgeschrieben im
koran und das ist auch gut die dort und
stelle sich das vor ort
verstorben
ist das heißt alles eingespielt
ausreifen und ich zeige und
verstorbene chancen eingeräumt eine
allfällige waschen als loot wohnen hier
von agenten oder gesehen
sind
[Musik]
nein war noch sehr klein hat sich in die
schweiz gegangen
seine ersten jahre habe ich leider
verpasst
erst als sein vater ihn mit zehn jahren
in die schweiz holte haben wir uns öfter
gesehen mein neffe war ein guter mensch
das kann ich sagen
[Musik]
mehr dazu im freundeskreis und
das fröhliche im fröhlich selber zu haus
und als oberster heime
einstimmig mit brot und wein taktisch
klasse und es einfach interessant sind
die
aufträge sind nämlich schon belastend
gesehen
mitternacht verfolgt nicht geschlafen so
dass die schlacht grund und ja zum
beispiel das ist der fall
mehrheitseigner
man muss das klar trainer berufliches
und privates und dass man das macht umso
besser kann man die methode gab es nimmt
endlich hat es mal mit bedankt immer
eigentlich ganz nicht trafen der
liebevolle familie und der hand junger
student seine große familie
das wird mich beschäftigen ich weiß
nicht wen ich damit tun würde sie zum
beispiel ihr vater war schmied stellt
eine das web vor der seite machen das
ist für mich selbstverständlich dass ich
das mache eigentlich
[Musik]
mir wurde mit dem vortrag wird er wieder
steigen dass moslems glaube ich verstehe
wenn man staaten
und private nummer da sein und der wird
dann entscheiden
kurzum was böses gemacht und dann war
das paradies oder
es kann nicht einmal fünf prozent foto
lied oder honig moschee dass sie
350.000 moslems die möglichkeit 20
musikern dem asche- und die andere
interessiert ist nicht groß das ist
sozusagen so grausam gläubiger nur
moschee oder baumteile die gebote gehört
und er
versteht was fertig
[Musik]
die letzte reise kostet 3000 franken all
inclusive egal wohin es geht dort fathi
und keine fünf prozent die letzte ruhe
in der schweiz finden obwohl
mittlerweile diverse friedhöfe
muslimische grabfelder anbieten wird das
angebot noch kaum genutzt
wenn sie maßstäbe möchten sie den
ausflug werden möchte die schweiz
beerdigt werden
ich mache eigentlich da werde ich
natürlich da aufgewachsen bin und
alles da gemacht haben kollege dach
familie da wenn nicht entscheide ich
würde da berichten
[Musik]
das leben führte sie in die schweiz und
der tod führt sie zurück in ihre heimat
das stimmt für die erste generation die
zweite wird vermutlich bleiben wollen
für immer
[Musik]
das presseportal ist eine albanische
entlarve auf serbischem gebiet ein paar
autominuten von der kosovarischen grenze
entfernt
[Musik]
hier wartete änderte seine ersten sechs
jahre darauf dass ihm das leben eine
perspektive eröffnen würde seine onkel
und cousins warten immer noch
den wintermonaten liegt die
arbeitslosigkeit hier nahe bei 100
prozent im sommer kommen die verwandten
die es ins ausland geschafft haben und
bringen ein wenig arbeit zuversicht und
geschichten die davon erzählen wie fängt
man sich geworden ist
mein start russland der see und in die
schweiz mit russland im schnitt mehr
gehört mir
so richtig dazu ja das ist mir
dass ich das gefühl
dass
ich wieder so ein samsung
zugehörigkeit soviel lytro dober und
griffen sich einsam man könnte aber doch
nicht interessant
lieder die nicht mit
armut
perspektivlosigkeit
ja
[Musik]
das leben gab ende keine chance und er
gab dem leben sein talent und seinen
fleiß er baute ein
bestattungsunternehmen auf und schuftete
gleichzeitig 80 prozent als
sachbearbeiter heute noch 60 prozent er
arbeitet und arbeitet als ob ihn die
armut dicht auf den fersen blieb mit 28
jahren hat er es bereits weit gebracht
so weit dass die sicht auf die heimat
allmählich verschwimmt
ihres die wahrscheinlich millionenwerte
note
millionen etat aber dass es
kalt und dass ich mal irgendein
anderes land hat kohl aber wohl nicht so
viel stress ausgesetzt ist so vielseitig
und einfach ja wo würden sie denn nun
zurücktreten so wird sie nicht
langweilig
langweilig als schwester und sie werden
richtig dazugehören ob es wäre dann
immer das schweizer ja das muss man mal
alle geräte sich
enttäuscht jugend eigentlich noch
schreiben auch vermitteln so enttäuscht
jugend noch nicht so
kaputt wie die schweiz also ausgang so
kenne sie nicht
zentrale bescheiden ist und
jugend kaputte die schweizer sicht was
meiner sicht ja
mertes wochen konnte er die teams kaum
alkohol drogen
los eine modellbasierte
respekt
vor den älteren wurde außer liegt
natürlich mit nach lissabon
idealisieren das könnte sich das könnte
sie wenn sie dann zurück um die
klimaziele oft wild bist du glücklich
das ist wahrscheinlich also aber ich
sage nur man sich die möglichkeit in
einem land optionsrechtes heimatlands
alle anderen hätten freilich gerne die
umgekehrte option bloß weg von
die schweizer lohne
garantiert
sozialversicherungsleistungen der
staatssicherheit herrschers und da
wir aber stress sogar straße
lebe stress
empfinden die glücklich sie die schweiz
von massa glücklich sah
im kanton solothurn hat sich als letztes
jahr ein schönes haus gekauft jenes in
dem er aufgewachsen ist steht seit
jahren leer hier wohnen nur noch die
erinnerungen an eine zeit in der sein
leben noch aus dem trügerischen schein
zu versäumen die möglichkeiten bestand
rohstoff denkbar einfach
da bin ich oft walter adams in herbern
ist großartig
anfang der 90er jahre kamen er und seine
zwei brüder in die schweiz es musste
aufwärts gehen das war klar
hatte
er ganz anders mehr erfolg dass man hat
desto
liebe sie sie mit einer pistole hatte
sie mit einem see oder regel mit ihm und
er wird ganz anders behandelt als
einheimische oder
schulbildung
ausgerichtet wird sicherlich über erfolg
das ist also das metall ist es ist so
dass auch die schweiz
es ist eine ironie des lebens dass
dieser erfolg nur möglich wurde weil er
sich seiner größten angst aus
kindertagen stellte der angst vor toten
er überwand diese angst und konnte eine
nische besetzen
neben ihm gibt es nur noch einen
muslimischen bestatter in der schweiz
[Musik]
mittlerweile ist der tod zu einem
vertrauten geworden die heimat zu
besuchen bedeutet für fathi heute immer
auch das familiengrab zu besuchen
[Musik]
das war einfach ein regelfall großvater
und großmutter
das ist eigentlich mehr und wartete
schon der glaube wird wenn man ablehne
liegt ich persönlich gespürt aber
die andere durch die
marketingkosten
ali gekommen
das ist wichtiger ist es die position
dass mit sinotruk suchen
und das gebet sprechen das ist schlecht
für ihre nicht malen
sterben
die letzte reise des verstorbenen neuen
care kelly geht ihrem ende entgegen dem
elternhaus in der kosovarischen stadt
kiel an eine autostunde von pristina
entfernt hier verbrachte er seine ersten
zehn geburtstage seinen 32 verbrachte er
in biel es war zugleich sein todestag
[Musik]
die familie nimmt abschied von einem
sohn von einem ehemann von einem bruder
einen vater von einem neffen und von den
usa
das alles seien ein kelly im leben
gewesen sagt seine familie bisher an
einem herzinfarkt gestorben sei
[Musik]
hilfe
ein jeder wird einmal den tod oder
leiden sagt der koran das kommen und das
gehen folgen einen göttlichen plan lehrt
der islam
wenn es ein buch vor dem ort ist und
bringt die sache mit seesternen und
bringt ich glaube zählt dass das rente
glaubt vodafone stufe satz aufschlag des
schicksals wird das sind alles erreicht
ich habe alles erfüllt drei mal aus und
drehte todestag wenn wird die person
starb es ist tolles kleid und vorheriger
vor gott das heißt wenn apples zu gott
kann wird nach rund 3 ist alles schon
vorher bestimmt und auch und eigentlich
zu ihm zurück und wagt man sich
eigentlich freuen wenn man vielleicht
traum eines raumes weltraum und so
sollte man sich aufregen über
das lager verloren und so eine chance
kommt
[Musik]
ich wollte meinen sohn hier beerdigen
weil das unsere heimat ist
wir wollen alle hier begraben sein ich
will auch hierher zurückkommen wenn ich
gestorben bin mit polen
unser sohn war ein guter sohn es gibt
keinen besseren auf der welt
ich werde für meine kinder weiterleben
ohne den mann mit dem ich elf jahre lang
verheiratet an einem valentinstag habe
ich mich für ihn entschieden und an
einem valentinstag muss ich nun begraben
gibt es etwas traurigeres
neben den angehörigen begleiten auch
engel den körper des verstorbenen zur
moschee glauben die muslime der
todesengel israel wird seine seele
derweil zu einem zwischenbericht im
himmel
[Musik]
hat der mensch ein gott wohl gefälliges
leben geführt wird die mitgeteilt dass
ihm alle seine sünden vergeben sind
haben der glaube und die taten des
verstorbenen vor gott keinen bestand
wird die seele zum versammlungsort der
verdammten gebracht
[Musik]
später führt der todesengel israel die
seele zurück ins grab wo sie in einer
art dämmerschlaf wartet bis zur
auferstehung am tag des jüngsten
gerichts
darum ist die ewige totenruhe so wichtig
für die muslime
das sieht der motionen natürlich
nachgeladene wenn der stunde person ist
heimatland wohnt und wenn man das ganze
geht also ich bin auch nicht trank sie
eigentlich
spielen sozusagen
also vor allem mit dem interview vor der
versicherer frau und auch das ist mir
achten
das schreibe der zusammenhalt war
gewaltsam in die kosmetik gestorben ist
sind jetzt die lytro vom tod von qantas
gebracht und trinkt und erscheint kurve
mit aktuell sind mega viel lytro
kontrollieren und sich das und
eigentlich extrem positiv finde
eine kultur
[Musik]
von hier ist ein kehlige kommen hierher
kehrt er nun zurück und empathie ist
plötzlich nicht mehr so sicher ob er
wirklich in der schweiz begraben werden
will
nachdem ich das sehe
muss ich mir man sich mit der suche noch
mal überlegt ich danke er ziehe mich
erst einmal nötig sei aber da der
emotion und die ganze anteilnahme und
die ganze lied und die schweiz kommt das
sind jetzt stand tropischen fischen und
jetzt nur die eigentlich sagen
und so endet diese geschichte mit der
erkenntnis dass wir unseren tod so
verbringen wie wir unser leben verbracht
haben die einen wie die anderen und die
anderen für sich
[Musik]